bioinformatics for infectious diseases  is an online training program designed  to introduce students clinicians and  researchers to the role and the  applications of bioinformatics in the  study of pathogenic microorganisms and  their interaction with the host which  lead to and enable human disease  by passing through the layers of immune  defenses and hijacking whole cell  machinery to replicate these  microorganisms  wreck havoc just to replicate so we  invite you to join this program on  bioinformatics for infectious diseases  where we will talk about different types  of pathogens and the diseases that they  cause  to learn about analysis approaches and  the leverage of bioinformatics to study  such pathogens  using curated projects and data sets and  applying tools that are easy to use for  even anonymous in this program we will  combine online sessions self-guided  study materials as well as practical  assignments